muy bien veamos un último ejemplo en
donde usemos inducción para demostrar
una igualdad aquí vamos a demostrar que
un medio más un cuarto más un octavo más
puntos suspensivos hasta uno entre dos a
la n es 2 a la n menos uno dividido
entre 2 a la em es decir vamos a hacer
el ejercicio 6 para eso vamos a empezar
como siempre en el paso base verdad
cuando n es igual a 1 entonces cuando en
es igual a 1 tendríamos que sumar un
medio hasta 1 entre 2 a la 1 que es un
medio entonces en realidad solo vamos a
tener un medio del lado izquierdo y
queremos ver si esto es igual a la
fórmula de la derecha tomando n igual a
1 es decir 2 a la 1 - 1 entre 2 a la 1 y
claramente esto es un medio verdad
entonces justamente tenemos la igualdad
ahora bien vamos a hacer el paso
inductivo supongamos que la fórmula que
tenemos es cierta para n igual acá
verdad entonces tendríamos un medio más
un cuarto más un octavo
puntos suspensivos + 1 / 2 a la k 2 a la
k menos 1 / 2 a la k lo que tenemos que
hacer ahora es demostrar que esta
fórmula es cierta para n e iguala a más
1 verdad es decir un medio más un cuarto
más un octavo más puntos suspensivos más
1 entre 2 a la k más el siguiente
término que sería 1 entre 2 a la cama 1
tendría que ser igual a la fórmula
cuando n es igual a camas o no es decir
2 a la camas 1 - 1 / 2 a la cama es uno
muy bien entonces vamos a utilizar la
hipótesis de inducción como usamos la
hipótesis de inducción bueno pues los
primeros términos por por la hipótesis
verdad tendría que valer esta suma 2 a
la k menos 1 entre 2 al acá y luego
sumamos el último término que es 1 / 2 a
la k más 1 entonces vamos a sumar estos
dos términos pero para poder lograrlo
necesitamos un denominador común
entonces
sumando digamos vamos a multiplicar
tanto en el numerador como en el
denominador por 2 verdad y así abajo
obtendríamos 2 a la cama 1 y arriba
tendríamos 2 por 2 a la que sería 2 a la
cama son no recuerden que que si tenemos
la misma base y multiplicamos sólo
sumamos exponentes y luego tendríamos
que restar 2 verdad que es 2 x menos 1 y
sumamos el otro término que era 1 entre
2 a la cama son muy bien entonces esto
cuánto es bueno ahora ya podemos sumar
verdad porque ya tenemos denominador
común y entonces tendríamos como
denominador 2 a la cama es 1 pero en el
numerador tendríamos 2 a la cama es 1 y
luego tendríamos menos dos más uno y eso
nos da menos 1 entonces podemos notar
que esto es justamente lo que teníamos
digamos esto era justo lo que queríamos
demostrar verdad queríamos que esto
fuera 2 al 2 alaca más uno menos uno
dividido entre dos a la cama es uno muy
bien entonces lo único que hicimos fue
utilizar o fue buscar un común
para poder hacer todas estas operaciones
y llegamos al resultado que queríamos
demostramos el paso inductivo y entonces
la afirmación original es cierta